[Music]
your testimony is Bob Muller did not
kick you off because of the content of
your text he kicked you all because of
some appearance that he was worried
about my testimony what you asked and
what I responded to was that he kicked
me off because of my bias I'm stating to
you it is not my understanding that he
kicked me off because of any bias that
it was done based on the appearance if
you want to represent what she said
accurately I'm happy to answer that
question but I don't appreciate what was
originally said being changed I don't
give a damn what you appreciate agent
strong I don't appreciate having an FBI
agent with an unprecedented level of
animus working on two major
investigations during 2016 in addition
to disappointing the hell out of my
Democrat colleagues that someone who is
investigating Russian collusion didn't
think there was any there there why
would you be concerned why would you not
be ecstatic that there was no collusion
why the word concern sir I don't know
what I'm in right that was more of the
fireworks at today's explosive hearings
House hearings with the disgraced FBI
agent Peter structuring is now the man
you just saw house government and
Oversight and Government Reform
Committee Chairman South Carolina
congressman trey Gowdy congressman good
to see you welcome back to program
thanks at the heart of this I think you
captured it there congressman and and
that is a bias and this man was in the
forefront of everything do you believe
as I do that Hillary Clinton had a
rigged investigation that she violated
the Espionage Act it was a big case of
obstruction with the emails deletions
and bleach pit and do you believe as I
believe that in fact he went after Trump
with a vengeance because of a political
view that he expressed often well let's
take trunk first before he ever began
investigating alleged collusion between
the Trump campaign and Russia he'd
already made up his mind that President
Trump would be destabilizing for the
country may think about how serious that
word is shown destabilizing for our
country and he had even begun to
interview the first person and in August
he said we'll stop it we need an
insurance policy and then he began
talking about impeachment one day after
Bob Mulder's investigation began so
Peter struck has a level of bias it
would make it impossible for any
prosecutor to stand in front of a jury
and use him as a witness on the other
hand while he's convicting Donald Trump
before the investigation begins
he's exonerating Hillary Clinton a
hundred million to zero is what the vote
ought to be and he hadn't interviewed
her and he hadn't interviewed thirty
other witnesses congressman and did you
believe his explanation as it relates to
his text messages I did not believe it I
did not believe the American people
believe what they saw today no the only
people who believe his explanation or
the thirty-some-odd emma-crats keep in
mind Shawn 60 Democrats have already
voted to move forward with impeachment
on President Trump and Bob Boehner had
released his first single solitary
finding so they've already made up their
minds of course they'd be sympathetic to
an FBI agent who's already made up his
mind he's the only person in America who
doesn't think he was biased he's the
only person in America that does not
understand how incredibly detrimental
those texts are to any kind of serious
investigation so look I spent 10 hours
with him two weeks ago about an equal
amount of time today
he just doesn't he thinks what his
personal opinion is is what the rest of
us call bias well yeah I guess that's
what we're the smelly people we'll go to
Walmart and as I mentioned in my model
on tonight I happen to be one of those
people I like Walmart not like Kmart and
I like Costco and I like Target and you
can get everything you want there and
you got a pretty good deal of every one
of those places but the more important
question you if I remember correctly you
were a prosecutor and you never lost the
case and am I correct in that sir I was
definitely a prosecutor yes sir that's
okay and you never lost a case I had
some very corrective sort of some sense
of good cops so what I want to ask in
this is really important what I am
worried about more than anything else
here
Laurie Clinton is allowed to take things
that are subpoenaed and delete them use
bleach bit on the hard drives have AIDS
break up devices and hammers and remove
SIM cards and move the desk B and ah
Jackie you cannot miss handle or destroy
classified or top-secret information
both those things happen he wrote an
exoneration with of course the FBI
director Comey in early May they didn't
interview her till July 2nd
she was exonerated on July 5th that to
me I you've been involved in these these
things do we have equal justice under
the law do we have equal application of
our laws no and that's what frustrates
people that's that's what frustrates
your viewers who wonder well would that
happen to me too when the director of
the FBI announced my innocence before
twenty-some-odd interviews have been
done including my own and keep this in
mind too Sean they were really clear
when they went into her interview she's
not going to be charged with anything
unless unless she lies
so the mishandling of classified
information she was never in jeopardy
from that even even before they
interviewed her so look I think
everybody would like that deal that the
the FBI was going to come talk to me the
only thing I got to do is tell the truth
yes I robbed the bank yes I kidnapped
this person yes I committed bank fraud
all you got to do is tell the truth and
you're going to get out of jail free
converse that with the fact that Donald
Trump not a single solitary witness had
been interviewed before Peter struck is
promising to stop him from ever becoming
president that is a dichotomy that
erodes public trust and our justice
system and in our law enforcement I'm
gonna have Jim Jordan on the program
after who also had a chance to question
Peter struck today I call when you add
the FISA abuse questions that he was
asking I called this the single biggest
abuse of power corruption scandal in
American history let's stay on what you
were just talking about was Peter struck
and others were they abusing their power
in an attempt
impact an American election in a way
that they saw fit to help one candidate
and hurt another candidate and what does
that mean if that can happen in the
United States of America congressman
well a politico's asian of law
enforcement is the end of us if we begin
to view that blindfolded lady holding a
set of scales is really having an R or a
D on her breastplate if that's where we
are that we're finished as a republic I
am proud to be on the house Intel
committee and we've done some really
important work on the FISA abuse
it's been a long slog we hadn't had a
lot of help at times but devon has made
really good progress on undercovering
what went into that FISA application so
I don't know I know this I know that
there were lots of things that should
have been in that application that was
presented to the judge that were not and
I know that they decided not to charge
her before they interviewed 30 fact
witnesses so if that is not a dichotomy
that we're going to withhold exculpatory
information in this case and we're going
to withhold any prospect of prosecution
in that case I don't know how anyone can
not be left with the conclusion that if
your name is Clinton you're gonna be
treated differently than if your name is
Jones or Smith what you're saying
congressman is really scary to me and
should should frighten every American I
want to ask you one last question what
now I mean Hillary Clinton had a rigged
investigation I think the evidence is
overwhelming and incontrovertible for
obstruction and for the Espionage Act
and a number of statutes we laid out
here what happens to her and what
happens to the people that were involved
in the exoneration before the
investigation to impact a presidential
election
never mind lying to for FISA judges to
get warrants to spy on Americans and
opposition party candidate
representatives which all this is where
I get myself in a little bit of trouble
because all of the the principal
decision-makers now were put in place by
President Trump Jeff Sessions Rod
Rosenstein Chris Rea
it's no longer Loretta Lynch and Eric
Holder and Jim Comey I mean it's our
folks so if they have uncovered systemic
abuse or any potential criminality they
have an obligation or prosecute it my
fear is when you have the head of the
FBI stand up in front of the entire
world and exonerate her the way Jim
Comey did I don't know a prosecutor in
the world that is good enough to win
that case so our opportunity to find out
whether or not she violated the
Espionage Act I think Jim Comey ruling
that ruin that they ruined it by not
interviewing her seriously
and then they ruined it but I don't
precedent a press conference so we'll
never know the answer of your question
all right congressman profound words I
hope the American people are paying very
close attention I think you did a great
job today we have a lot of ground to
cover